hello and welcome to Android design in
action this is our first episode of this
brand-new show my name is Roman Nurik
from the Android developer relations
team we are broadcasting here from New
York City we're also joined by Nick
butcher who is a guest to my screen left
and he's coming from London Nick you
want to say hi hi and we also have a
special guest in the back Adam Kosh also
from the New York Android developer
relations team and he is producing the
show today he'll be providing some color
commentary here and there as he sees
appropriate and yeah so that's the
that's the team kicking off this very
first Android design in action now I'm
guessing many of you don't really know
much about the show since this is our
first time and we haven't really talked
much about it very briefly I just want
to talk about the brief history so many
of you are already followers of the
Friday app clinic and in that app clinic
some of our teammates including Radio
Meyer Daniel Pham and Ian Lewis they
look at apps that are nominated to the
team through Google moderator they look
at those apps and they inspect ways in
which they can you know improve the apps
they look at you know what potentially
could be fixed what what the apps do
wrong things like that and so this this
show is basically a spin-off show kind
of to look at the design specifically
look at the visual and interaction
design aspects of some of these apps and
see how those can be improved so today
in this first show we're gonna look at
three apps from the the Friday app
clinic we're gonna look at the London
Underground app the London bus checker
app and M parking and we're gonna look
at those specific screens from those
apps and look at how we can kind of
reimagine or rework them to better
follow our guidelines from the Android
design site and in general how to just
overall improve the design of the apps
so with that let's get started let's
look
the very first step we're switch to the
demo here and you can see that we're
using a fancy little setup using a drop
box thanks to the developers of the
Dropbox app we're gonna look at the very
first app which is London Underground so
you know this is actually one of the
screens from the app this is the live
information screen you get to this get
to this screen from the top level one
there's this little icon it's kind of
like an exclamation point that gets you
to the screen and it basically tells you
the status the state of the different
lines on the underground gives you
things like access to weather if you
look down here it gives you access to
weather at the very bottom and then it
also tells you like the current
departure boards and then it actually
even notices in this is something that I
noticed checking in from New York it
notices that you are not actually in
London and it notices that you're in New
York City and it says hey you know we
actually have an app for that we have a
New York City version of this app
available and that leads you to the Play
Store to get that version so it's pretty
straightforward screen Nick do you have
any initial comments on kind of the
screens useless since you are you know
coming from London you have any ideas
yeah yeah you're doing two london-based
apps with me here in London I think when
I look at this screen you pulled out the
first thing I think is it's fairly iOS
styles that's my gut reaction where you
have the kind of the rounded white
sections that's the first thing which
I'm having me reading they have made an
attempt to adopt some things like we
have an action bar
although choosing some some slightly
non-standard styling within which we'll
get into later but yeah the first thing
that jumps out to me is is the iOS nice
yeah absolutely and you could tell just
by you know like you mentioned the the
kind of rounded grouped list items and
in this gray background so yeah that's
definitely kind of a styling from a
different platform so that's one of the
third first things you'll notice in the
redesign coming up one of the first
things that we changed the other thing
the thing that stuck out to me was you
know
a lot of space dedicated here to showing
all the different lines all the
different lines of the London
Underground for example the Bakerloo the
central the Circle Line and all of them
have good service so it seems like it's
just showing a lot of information that's
the same it's not really useful
information seeing that everything is
good service so if I'm say taking the
Waterloo line you'll notice here in the
second screenshot this is kind of the
scrolled down version if you scroll down
then you have to you know find Waterloo
and then only then see that there's
minor delays so that was one thing that
struck out to me that to see any actual
I guess actionable information about the
status of certain lines you have to
scroll and that's that's never a good
thing
actually as a Londoner if I'm putting
out this app I'm going to the live
information it's probably because I you
know I'm heading towards a specific line
and I want to know if there's anything
going on so I want that information in
like first but first and foremost right
at the top yeah okay so let's let's talk
a little bit about some of the other
interactional elements so the first
thing you well one of the first things I
the other one of the second things I
guess I noticed was that there's no up
button right so this is a subsequent
screen so there should be some way of
getting up in the hierarchy of the act
there's there's an icon here but there's
no up caret indicating you can go up the
other thing is that the action bar has a
bold title and while that's you know
sometimes okay well that's often okay
it's a little non-standard so it kind of
takes takes away some of the visual
attention from the content of the screen
and also this is kind of curious there's
an update button somewhere in the middle
here and really that's probably
something that should be kind of like a
refresh action potentially in the action
bar so with that one yet on the action
bar icon like didn't we come across in
screenshot but the highlight is
non-standard as well so when you touch
the icon the highlight behind it is kind
of tall and narrow like there's a very
there's a very standard max limit
there's a very standard kind of size and
shape that you would expect with these
controls and that's probably important
the importance of the actionbar that is
very familiar to the users so every time
you kind of deviate from from that
standard kind of size and shape then all
of a sudden it's introducing like a
common typical kind of speed bump
do we users where something just feels
slightly off yeah I'd say it sounds
maybe but that can give really
contributes to making your app feel very
easy to you yeah the last thing I want
to point out before we jump into the
redesign version is the send us feedback
link generally for things that are
secondary things like you know settings
or send feedback or logout or things
like that we generally try to put that
into the action overflow since that's
really what it's for it's for
Corrections that you know users wouldn't
really use in a regular basis you know
so you know if 10% of the time even 1%
of the time they're gonna be using send
us feedback you may want to just go put
it in the action overflow so moving on
we're gonna we're running a little short
in time I guess for this part let's jump
into the redesign so this is a
reimagining of this screen and I'm going
to quickly zoom in here and so you'll
notice that we've changed some of the
some of the colors one of the things
that we started with was the the dark
action bar theme and this isn't kind of
you know something that you should do
for any app but it kind of conveys a
pretty nice contrast between actions and
screen content also we put weather as a
second tab that you can swipe over to
since weather is you know potentially
something that that is fairly important
this isn't kind of necessary but you
know it is it is a nice touch the other
thing that you'll notice here is that we
we took that list of all the different
lines the circle line the Bakerloo line
the district line we collapsed that only
into what the user wants to see which is
exceptions right exceptions to the
almost always well running lemon on the
ground so in this case you'll notice
that is that true Nick is the under gun
actually done pretty well yeah awesome
so right now I'm guessing that we would
see no exceptions in the South but so
you see that you know the circle line is
closed and this is just you know
an imaginary situation the circle line
is closed there's a little bit of
iconography to indicate that on top of
the yellow color for the circle line and
then minor delays and the Waterloo line
you see that below and you'll see that
we actually use holo styling throughout
we use these kind of standard list
headings that have this kind of all caps
12 SP text and then below those two
exceptions we actually just say as a as
kind of an additional confirmation to
the user that all the other lines have
good service on them
the other thing I'll quickly point out
here is that for the travelling in New
York City
I guess toast or pop-up that's kind of
an exceptional case that rarely happens
likely so what you may want to do there
is actually just show up a kind of like
a bottom toast or a bottom bar that
slides in and lets the user take action
and if they don't really care about New
York City if I just happen to
accidentally open the app in New York
City just press the X to dismiss that
and never show it to them again so Nick
with that you have any any thoughts on
this well immediately this feels much
more like at home of my on my Android
device it feels it fits in with the
system that can feel using the holo
styling I especially like the said color
we've gone through here it really made
the person information jump out to me
and things like air about when I'm
opening the lines they status is you
know what is close what's going to be
playing my journey and I think goodies
the points to the app already pop after
me now so that's my favorite a quick you
know awesome the other quick things will
point out before jumping into the next
next app is that there's a refresh
button here in the action bar to convey
that you can refresh everything on the
screen and that's that's kind of the
standard place to put something like a
refresh on Android and then for the
other piece the view departure boards
over here we move that as well into the
action bar as an icon up top
oh and Adam points out that we should
probably mention the ad
so you'll notice them in the original
screen here there's an ad at the bottom
there's nothing really preventing you
from from using that same ad in the
bottom here the only thing that really
would distract from is the traveling in
New York City banner but in that case
you may want to consider you know that's
really an ad for yourself that is
effectively a house ad right so maybe
that could cover up or if that is the
case if you are traveling in New York
City hide the other ads and show this
kind of house out and when you dismiss
maybe show the other ends so that's I
think it for for me make any parting
thoughts for London again yeah I think
just and if you take a look at this
t-shirt shorts next to each other you
can notice there's much less kind of
chrome around the content is instead of
using bounding boxes and different
background colors to give the app
structure we've used typography and
consistent spacing to really convey the
same information a much cleaner way
which for me makes the content pop out
much more but also I think this is the
you know this like I saw really sums up
the holiday life design philosophy very
nicely awesome all right so with that
let's move on to the next app the next
app is M parking and so this basically I
don't really know how to use this app
because I think parking in the States
works a little differently
NIC any thoughts on on M parking yes I'm
here in London there's a few schemes
like this way you can pay for your
parking fee by sending an SMS to a
certain premium number and that will you
Becky SMS in your vehicle registration
plate and that will kind of give you
parking for a period of time so this app
lets you set up certain zones which work
with it with appropriate SMS now let's
attach them and then you just hit a
button and it sends this its message
interesting so and you try this out at
what point that it actually send the SMS
was it outside of the screen so the
screen we're looking at now is one of
the cert ones this is where you actually
configure a parking zone what are you
entering the number that you need to SMS
to and how on that kind of covers you
for so once you've configured this then
on
on the very like homescreen it'll show
all the zones you've configured and the
car registration numbers you say so the
first we see when you open the app is
just hit that one of the zones you've
saved and it will send the message and
basically give you parking access so
this is one of the kind of setup screens
you would go through in configuration
you have to do this step so basically
you wouldn't use this on an everyday
basis right so things like speed and
like you know in general if you're using
something on an everyday basis you want
to minimize the number of inputs right
you want to make it quick and easy for
the user to just you know fly through
and obviously not make mistakes but this
is kind of an auxilary screenwriting
yeah I can imagine you probably install
this app and configure three or four
parking zones which you commonly click
plan yeah okay so let's talk about what
we would change in this screen so the
first thing that jumped out at me was
that there's a Save icon and in general
we you know borrowing the whole
discussion of whether a floppy disk is
actually a useful metaphor these days
for save you know there's two ways to
basically leave the screen actually
three ways if you count the back button
as well and this is something that I
recently posted about I'm in a post
about the done button we'll talk about
that in a moment
but basically here I can press back or
up or save to basically get out of the
screen and it doesn't seem to be a
doesn't seem kind of like a specific
affordance for discarding changes or
reverting that's a whole issue in itself
but that was the first thing that stuck
out to me that there's there's a lot of
ways to save and get out of the screen
the other thing is that just purely from
a visual standpoint the blue action bar
and the blue screen content didn't
really mesh well for me
generally in in this kind of app where
you're entering data lots of data you
want to you probably want to use like a
lighter background I think the darker
backgrounds like a black or any of the
holo dark theme those are best used for
media apps like gallery or playing video
and so when I'm entering when I'm
entering text or entering data it seems
like it's a better fit for a lighter
theme the the darker color action bar
the blue action bar is fine for branding
but that's just kind of one of the first
things that rip down
second thing was around visuals right so
you have labels here like a name SMS
number price things like that
so the problem there is that they're not
really aligned with the content itself
so you have I'm I'm gonna butcher this
tariff break one and then the SMS number
and they're not visually aligned with
the rest of the text so that was another
thing and lastly I just wanted to point
out that this color chooser seems a
little simplistic you actually can't
tell this from the screenshot but the
background color is the currently
selected color so if I touch yellow here
it would actually change the background
color of that to yellow so that's it's
not a very common way of indicating
selection so with that Nick any thoughts
on the screen now you pretty much know
that I think they've basically taken the
color palette from the icon and run a
little bit too far of it in my book
especially when they haven't customized
the holo control pills where I find that
the blue underlined in the text boxes
doesn't really contrast highly with the
background color been making it and
making the focus get lost little bit
yeah yeah absolutely and actually I just
want to make a call-out since you
mentioned that Nick someone and I forget
your name I'm very sorry someone has
actually recently created a generator
for styling for holo styling so you can
just punch in a few colors and you can
generate all the different assets for
four buttons for text boxes things like
that so it's this developer you know
wanted to disregard our feedback about
the light color and wanted to have a
lighter color for the text field the
little bottom bar they could use the
holo I think it's called a holo style
generator will link to that afterwards
okay so let's let's jump into the
redesign so here's a redesigned version
of that screen you'll notice immediately
that we we switched from using save and
up to a single done button and this one
errors what you would see in the people
app for example on Ice Cream Sandwich
and later so when you edit a contact
you're presented with this similar kind
of screen for entering data the other
thing we did here was that
we took the the I guess the city the
location and we used and this is I think
one of make and my favorite things to do
is turn that into a Roboto light or
actually in this case maybe even Roboto
thin large text to indicate that this is
the current general vicinity that you're
working with the zone you're editing is
in Berlin the other thing you'll notice
is that we we realigned all of the
labels and actually we remove the name
label because it's almost
self-explanatory that you're currently
editing this specific zone but we took
all the other labels like SMS number and
period suffix and we aligned them with
the content and this is something that
is a little tricky to do the framework
currently but it's something that you
can actually do correctly with a couple
of tweaks here padding the other thing
is that we dropped period suffix so if
you notice here period suffix was to the
right of SMS number and that conveyed to
me at least it conveyed a sense of
sequence so that like the period suffix
is almost the suffix to the SMS number
and again speaking this is coming from
somebody that doesn't really know how
parking in Europe works but it was kind
of it's kind of a weird connection to
make that period suffix was that sir
after SMS number so you move that down
to the bottom and then lastly we we made
this color changer and actually switch
to the next slide we had this color
changer that when you touch it it gives
you a drop-down of the different colors
you can choose from and then you can
select you know which color you want to
change to and it shows a little blue
rectangle around the currently selected
color and then it also lets you discard
changes if you select the action
overflow it lets you discard changes
that you've made here so that's a
high-level summary of what we've done
here Nick any thoughts yeah immediately
for me I find the the light theme works
very well for the data entry screen
screams it's very kind of easy on the
eye to scan and enter quickly and I'm
just lining everything up for me makes
just makes this this screen flow a lot
more little much better rhythm like the
designers tend to talk about grids and
and rhythms I've got that but basically
it just means line stuff up and use a
use the standard amounts of panic I mean
as programmers we can weaken down board
with that kind of instruction and it
just helps make things really easy and
quick to scan yeah absolutely I want to
put up for me well like I'm one of one
of the most important things in this
kind of input screen as well is is using
the appropriate input types so this is a
field you can set on your edit texts
then continue and the system what client
take the input so you can say it's gonna
be a number field a number of decimals
or gonna be you know proper name where
it might capitalize every letter and I
think that's really critical for making
these screens like flow very fast and
make you both adopt it so but there's
not them too bad a job if step number
five in the pipes and a couple of the
fields but not all of them so I'd like
to see those and use for out yeah very
good point I do want to just add on one
little point to the line stuff up point
you made there Nick in a recent Google
i/o video I believe it was advanced
design for engineers Christian Robertson
who is the lead visual designer for
Android he mentioned this kind of
concept of lining stuff up as part of
the discussion of Gestalt principles or
just out principles and pronounce it but
that was that was kind of something that
definitely stuck out line stuff up is a
very very kind of easy way to make
things instantly look cleaner I think
that's where I borrowed the line echo
again like the you sit for long tail
light and you know typography can really
really help give the structure and
emphasis to your application I think
this is a great example of setting it
like a head in here and and it really
pops out bring you through nuts yeah
totally Adam had a point about discard
Adam what was that point again
oh yeah yeah so atoms are just pointing
out that we also have discard right so
in the previous screen you there wasn't
really an obvious way or like me you
know when you press back or up it's
really up to the developer to decide
what to do there we don't have strong
guidance on whether upper-back should
save it generally should in cases where
you have you know really really
destructive operations if savers are
really destructive operation like it
posts a tweet or something or or a post
to the entire world you probably want to
have some sort of confirmation or
something but having that discard in the
action overflow gives that extra extra
sense of certainty as to what that
action will do so moving on to the last
app we're gonna look at London bus
checker actually Nick since you're in
London do you wanna just briefly talk
about what this app will do for you yeah
absolutely so it's a an application to
find the nearest bus stops to you and
tell you the roots of those buses and
how how long you'll have to wait into
the next bus arrive okay awesome so it's
it's basically exactly that right tells
you where but it's it's your guide to
the bus system in London effectively
yeah it slides into the system thank you
you know when you get the bus stop it
tells you like five minutes the next
class so this can is but not every stop
has that but apparently there is
information so this apps actually super
handy around London to find out how long
you're gonna have to wait for a bus
awesome so I use it I pick this up I
bought it
okay so Nick is an avid user of this app
so let's see how we can you know fit you
know fix this you want and not really
necessarily fixed but improve so one of
the one of the first things that I
noticed was that this map drop-down this
is the zooming is kind of wonky right
now
this map drop-down this spinner is kind
of off in its own place somewhere in the
middle of the action bar I don't know if
that's intentional or just because the
logo is really wide but that's kind of
like a weird place for it also the the
logo here the the placement of the logo
in the action bar and the
the blue I guess hollow dark border at
the bottom of the action bar just seems
kind of out of place especially in it's
such a visually rich app like this the
other thing I'll note is that these
these buttons here kind of have styling
from a different platform and you can't
see this in the screenshot but touching
on the bubble doesn't actually do
anything to get into the in or to see
the details for that stop you have to
touch on the this blue button here and
then this is basically a shortcut to see
the bus route map for that stuff the bus
the bus route is actually one of the
most useful functions of this
application you can you know rock up to
a random bus stop and hit the root
button and see exactly where that bus is
going to take you but I don't feel that
at all conveyed by this butter it's its
button on the left of the bubble and
then repeated in this action bar at the
bottom they're kind of free gas
connected it isn't screen route to me
maybe yeah and the other thing is it
just maybe it's just me but it resembles
sharing so the share action icon and
this is something that you know users I
ICS devices especially are extremely
familiar with share it's used throughout
the entire operating system and the icon
for share is basically this icon with
filled circles and flipped horizontally
so it may just kind of convey that
unintentionally so that's another thing
that jutted out right was that it just
it seems like a version of share but
it's not it's it's completely separate
it's a bus it's a route map and that's
it
straight straight off of another battle
yeah the other thing is again you can't
see this in the screenshot but the
bottom icons were blurry they seem to
just be either mdpi or HTTP eye
resources you should really and this is
just you know for everybody out there
should really provide xhdpi resources
for your apps because you know lots and
lots of devices that are out now and
coming out
they have xhdpi screens so with that any
parting thoughts Nick on the current
screen nice straight into the redesign
okay so the redesigned version is here
and you notice immediately and
maybe I should just stop zooming and let
the camera do its trick
you're gonna start immediately here we
got rid of the D branding up top and
this is kind of controversial a lot of
folks may think oh but I want my brand
to be visible at all times
but you have to remember that this is an
application that users use every day if
they're launching into your app they
probably know that they're using bus
tracker right so it's not necessarily
it's not necessary to always show your
branding sure you can show an icon
you know if icon if your Nikon
represents your brand really strongly
then show it in this case just to me
personally the icon was you know is very
it has a lot of different things going
on in it and so it doesn't seem like a
great representation of the brand and so
what we did instead was we thought maybe
let's pick a strong highlight color
strong accent color to represent the
brand better in this case we just chose
kind of like a reddish pink and you can
see that in the action bar there's kind
of this reddish pink outline underlined
and then in the in each of the markers
and the map it also uses that color we
also decided to show some additional
branding in the background of the tab
bar so basically you see the TfL logo
there you probably you probably
shouldn't use the TfL logo as is but
that's just an example of somewhere
where you can put some sort of square
like branding additionally very quickly
since we're running a long time we put
the the locate me button in line in the
map since that's kind of something that
users of Google Maps will be accustomed
to we've also simplified some of the
icons at the bottom we've changed the
icon for the route map to an actual map
and this is actually based on some
iconography from from a black man his
name oh my god
Nick say again yes absolutely Gunther
Gunther from Germany I feel horrible
Gunther if you're watching sorry for
forgetting your name on the spot but
Gunther's provided a couple of icons I
think they're called Android icons calm
or something he's provided a bunch of
additional icons
in addition to the action bar icon pack
and so this is based on a map down there
and so this conveys a map of a route and
you can't really see it in the icon but
it's it's kind of two points with a
route in between and then lastly here we
we changed this this bubble this pop up
bubble so that it uses a styling very
similar to the Maps app and touching on
the entire bubble will take you to the
details as opposed to having this kind
of separate icon here and then there's
this additional action button that takes
you to you know takes you to the route
map so that's that's a very high level
the redesign Nick any any thoughts yeah
one of my favorite changes here is the
use of the overlay action bar as well I
mean I think that really with the map
application especially really really
stands out that you get to see this kind
of like whole logic canvas across the
way I think that works pretty well here
as well yeah and Adam pointed this out
as well so you can see here what we did
here was we used not a black action bar
but it's I think it's like one one one
or two to two hex color with opacity so
even setting the opacity to like 90
percent and using it like Nick mentioned
in overlay mode gives the feeling that
the entire screen is really your canvas
the map moves across the entire screen
so that definitely helps convey a sense
of a sense of you know content is in
front of you and infinitely Panna Bowl
basically okay so it's 11 o'clock I
think that that's it for this week but
before we cut off any parting thoughts
from Nick first and I'll go after no
well I hope that this will match working
well for everyone but I am I think it's
a really good way to demonstrate a
before and after a good way to
demonstrate the strengths of designing
for the platform and how you can really
remake your application feel right at
home on Android and therefore feel
easier to use your users so yeah I hope
you guys can do it yeah and I just want
to mirror that absolutely know if you if
you do like to format definitely you
know
comments either on the event or in any
of the related posts on the Google+ page
for Android developers and if there's
anything you'd like to see changed or
anything you'd like to see in the future
added or whatever definitely let us know
this is like we mentioned the very
beginning this is a very new show so
we're still exploring different ideas
different ways of getting design in your
hands design in action so yeah let us
know and thanks everyone for tuning in
and we'll see you next time